hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys I'm
Andrew Andrew and I saw Mission
Impossible rogue nation today we're
bringing you our spoiler review alright
so we can just take this from the
beginning that opening sequence with the
plane I love how they introduced each
character because even if you don't know
Mission Impossible I feel like you get a
good sense of who these characters are
just from the interaction of how they
introduce them you know also point out
what what their specific job is to help
even Honda it's not the Tom Cruise shows
showing what the supporting test is and
I think that's the biggest strength of
this franchise is the supporting cast so
I loved how they incorporated that in
the first minute of the film and that's
what I felt about Tom Cruise in this
film he sees a leader to a team
absolutely you know it was in Ghost
Protocol he's like I need a team but I
kind of want to do this on my own you
know absolutely in this one it's like
you see him as a survivor and then he
learns to be a leader yeah they're
they're a for-sure an established team
by the by the beginning of this film and
they work great together
he looks incredible just on all these
action sequences like how old is this
dude went believe it looks great about
Tom Cruise he believes every moment you
know he's a very in the moment intense
actor it was cool how they sort of
established our villain he's not some
guy who's just all about you know
dictating you see him kill a person up
front and Tom Cruise has to witness that
and it's his fault she died everything
he does is completely calculated yeah
two steps ahead of the play it's not hey
I'm the bad guy I'm shooting you now
this is a revenge I know everything he
does in this film he is two steps ahead
of you finish the mental game between
the bagging and the and the good guy
loved it I love how they set it up at
the beginning to just like you who the
heck kisses go what's it about and I
love like you know that misdirect and
just we had no idea what's gonna happen
just by the end of it a great villain
and they shoes Alec Baldwin I love what
they do with the character cuz I'm like
okay yeah another character that's like
[ __ ] IMF what they did with him like you
and I love the ending of that to me that
ending put a big smile on my face just
to not see it coming
me personally I thought maybe he was
gonna be a bad guy or something I wasn't
sure exactly what was gonna happen but I
thought he was gonna have one tone in
the particular film and he was gonna
stay that way the whole film
I forget IMF I don't want I love how his
character really had a great arc and how
they established it yeah it was a
cliffhanger and it's like an
intellectual cliffhanger I don't know
more than just him going you guys are
alright IMF he would they be he because
I love how they incorporated that now
it's like okay I can see them go into
this guy for problems and the next film
went something catastrophe you know a
catastrophe happens like this franchise
getting the better and Petter would
happen you would think but it's like
Fast Five I've you know rebooted itself
really really yeah this movie is not
rebooting itself it's more getting
better each time I know what they did
with Benji was really cool because they
really flushed him out even more they
gave him something more personal because
in the fourth one and third one you're
like he's the funny guy any guy but in
this one they gave him a full character
you know they show up front that he's
just [ __ ] like doing a job that he
does not like it you know he's [ __ ]
slacking off playing video Halo yeah and
you always see Benji like Shh and now
he's just like I'm [ __ ] playing video
games I hate my job when he was being
tested at the lie detector I loved that
scene because you and he's being tested
he's saying like what he doesn't like
Tom Cruise and it's [ __ ] not jumping
that was brilliant and written at the
very end jump once Alec Baldwin leaves
like he like takes a little second to
breathe and then it jumps up a little
he's like I'm like okay now you know
he's really little you can right there
he had to be there he served a purpose
each scene that he was there if he's not
there in a certain scene
Ethan Hunt cannot complete that part of
a mission he was these essentially
Ethan's number two in a lot of ways
Natalie especially now that Jeremy
Renner was kind of sidelined in the
Benjy doesn't get asked to be a part of
the messed up for a tickets right yeah
but even after the opera scene conquers
like you can go on go but someone petty
was like no any any fights to be there
yeah no and you really makes you loved
again I love Tom Cruise's reaction he's
like I'm not going anywhere and that's
that one ben says him he goes okay what
I loved about the film to the tone it
was so suspenseful I like even though
you know Ethan Hunt is gonna win at the
end I feared for his life most of the
film and and his team in the team's life
the tone of the film the suspenseful
tone and the comedic timing was just so
perfectly made
again christopher mcquarrie free job on
the script you know he's gonna live at
the inch okay that's cool but it's about
what this movie does great is it puts
you it knows how to immerse you into its
moments where you feel the danger of the
situation absolutely that you're not
thinking oh wait he's gonna be a lie by
the end you know it puts you in that
moment oh yeah at the Opera House I love
that sequence I love the misdirects in
that scene to be but just from Rebecca
Ferguson we had just seen her save Tom
Cruise's life and so we weren't exactly
sure and then we see her pointing a gun
at the Chancellor and we're like whoa
what's going on here like I love the
mister again that's him he's about to
fight that big that big was like Russian
or whatever that guy was and I forgot
what he was but that big dude when he
stands up to Tom Cruise and he sees that
biggie is like oh crap and then and then
they're fighting it was so creative to
what they were fighting I was so
creative those fight sequences what was
great about it is it never felt
repetitive they were all so [ __ ]
different that fight sequence there and
because they have to be kind of quiet
about it because they can't draw too
much attention you know cuz they're in
an opera house and this could go down
worse if everyone [ __ ] hears you know
you know the part where he had the gun
he just and he gives the guy a flush and
was like that's brilliant I love those
like I had no idea how he was gonna get
out of that scene so that was really
smart right there I mean the
introduction of Rebecca Ferguson was
great you know Tom Cruise gets captured
I love how there's [ __ ] in this movie
that we've seen in other movies before
but rather than trying to build up to it
they get it all out of the way upfront
yeah you know that big secrets have been
priority in the trailer we're gonna pit
as the first scene you know that see
where Tom Cruise is captured yeah that's
gonna be like the Thursday you know the
way he got out of this situation was
cool I didn't know it seemed possible to
actually get out the way he was doing it
you know what Rebecca Ferguson she was
phenomenal I'm just gonna call her the
much prettier version of Milla Jovovich
that's what she is
that's all she does well she was amazing
in the film too I'm not gonna live
actually she really shocked me with her
acting the slow scenes with just
dialogue I really thought that she was
in Aden and I thought her motivation she
was very good and I cared about her and
I had wanted her to live Heena
absolutely she wasn't just a really sexy
woman to look at she could she was a
badass
yeah and again speaking of Milla
Jovovich I got a lot of that Fifth
Element bad
you know the here Owens she's just the
most lethal spy weapon and like she
would be a great addition to Ethan's
team for sure I love to how they didn't
kiss at the end yes because that would
have been bad for two reason for two
reasons I can see one would have been
cliche - it would have totally negated
the fact of how Tom Cruise was like I
got to protect my wife and I'm doing
this on my own week two you know to keep
her safe you know I love how they still
get out into that it's not you know
they're not cheating on what happened in
the first in the previous two films so I
love that they kept that up and I
thought that was a great ending where
they did not kiss they just they had the
tension that there were they're really
attracted to each other but there was no
actual kiss like you said would have
been very cliche I'm glad they chose
that because they're characters in this
movie they both know like especially
with Tom Cruise of what we understand of
him he probably never wants to be in a
relationship again yeah and the scene -
really quick where she says to him we're
basically fighting an endless war for
our governments there's nothing that
we're fighting for no let's get away get
away I'm like she's absolutely right
that I love how Tom Cruise was tempted
but yeah yeah because I was thinking how
many times is Tom Cruise saved the day
this is his fifth time saving the day
and they still want to and now he's a
fugitive me now he's a fugitive for
saving the day four times like why do
you what are you fighting for dude you
can see that this guy is just struggling
so much he's a survivor at this point
he's someone who has to be on his own he
knows he's a fugitive the beard looked
fake whatever but he's you see that he's
a guy who's just being pushed to his
limits I love what they called him in
the film the bad guy called him a
gambler that's like the perfect way to
describe Ethan Hunt he gets luck team of
him is like he gets lucky
he takes risk and he just gets lucky and
I love how they made like a legendary
story about him where people or someone
was like all the stories about you can't
be true the water tank sequence oh my
god when I saw that in the trailer we
know when he's gonna dive it was like
okay I'm assuming there's water but what
is going to be a cool five minutes CGI
sequence I had no that I mean that thing
and for me personally that was way
better than the in the first movie where
he's bungee jumping down that was
basically the underwater version of that
and I love the technology these with the
oxygen on this thing where it showed
like
much breathing room he had left and then
you saw I also love the way they use the
camera in the shower they're going
around and showing a fascicle and then
you see the thing swooping around and
like it just misses Tom the first time
like oh dude he's got to watch that that
might get him in the next time and then
bang he gets him you're like man I love
how the whole theater to just gasps yeah
the way they shot it was not a lot of
cutting around and it didn't and you
could tell Tom Cruise was underwater you
know that thing looked a little fake but
yeah it's it's so in the moment like I
compared that moment to watching gravity
that you're underwater I just I was
gonna say I almost felt like I couldn't
breathe
watching that sequence it was awesome
she saves him that was so [ __ ] cool
yeah because it just makes you go so
back and forth yeah it is and what the
people are really talking about too is
the car chase that turns into a
motorcycle race you know I love the way
they did that man cuz Tom Cruise in a
car gets so much about her cycles it's
like it looks great it's intense but
there's also the feeling like well he
just has something done em you know yeah
yeah and then with the car like you
could tell that was real you know like I
can't tell if stalkers is really in
there but you could tell that was a real
stuff pretty sure he does just about all
his stunts but in this the sequence and
the Beamer with her back flipping like
yeah back flipping and then they land
and I love when Jeremy comes in there to
save them at the 4x4 and then
immediately we go right from that car
sequence right into yours I was like now
we're not taking a break let's go pump
it up 120 now and go into a crazy add
and what I loved about that motorcycle
sequence with the Christopher Porter in
the DP the director of photography did
they put the camera a lot of times on
the bikes so you got a lot of the POV
shot so it felt like we the audience it
felt like we were riding the Blackson
like I felt like I was falling over
about to hit the ground it was putting
me in an uncomfortable position in a
good way and the fact that Tom Cruise
really did know with no helmet I won't
point my girlfriend whisper to me I'm
sure for this guy's like she said is
that really Tom Cruise like there's no
way like you could tell like when some
stuff was vision like they visual FX you
know gars and [ __ ] yeah of course but
you could tell when it was real you know
this movie
had time for good character moments I
really like the scene when Tom Cruise
and Jeremy Renner yell at each other
because it's more than just know here's
why I believe in here's what you believe
it was like hey Tom
I mean hey Ethan you're obsessed and for
a second there you see how on edge Ethan
is that you're like is he obsessed you
know makes it makes you question what
Jeremy Renner's questioning and I loved
how big reigns was so consistent in his
trusted even Oh like how jeremy renner
and steam and simon pegg were like i
don't know and but being rams was like
and then what jeremy renner snitches i
will say like we talked about this
earlier i believe that moment for Jeremy
Renner's character what I didn't think
was Tom
it wasn't like Oh Ethan I was gonna get
screwed isn't know about this I thought
Ethan home was gonna like use this to
his advantage in some way but I wasn't
expecting Jeremy Renner to be in on it I
had a feeling something was gonna happen
I wasn't exactly sure I knew there's got
to be a purpose for the snitch I figured
Tom Cruise there Ethan Hunt knew about
what was what was happening when he
snitched but I didn't you know know I
wasn't sure if are they in on it
together on the snitch or is he
snitching right underneath and not
knowing if he down knows if he's
snitching on him the head of mi6 I love
how they they unwrapped that old thing
you know with Tom Cruise wearing the
mask it's like Tom Cruise just believed
in this so much and he he had to prove
it to Allie Baldwin to love how and they
loved that it wasn't just hey this is
the good you heard yes filling their gut
saying if he can't it wasn't like it
wasn't like Tom Cruise saved the day and
they show up with a bunch of cops yeah
it was like Alec Baldwin is witnessing
this is why IMF is so [ __ ] important
when Tom Cruise saves Benji's life yes I
think that was one of my favorite scenes
in the entire films I love simon Pegg's
performance the sweat on his fate the
look on his face like you felt oh my god
yeah this guy's gonna die right now and
you can just see from Rebecca Ferguson
like oh [ __ ] she's she's gonna die too
oh you know yeah and then when Tom
Cruise shows up it was a brilliant
moment how Tom Cruise was using
intellect not physicality it's not
trying to just shoot the guy take him
down kill a bunch of bad guys he was
using his intellect when we were talking
about like not being repetitive in the
film's I don't need to see Ethan Hunt
always kicked the
main bad guys ass you know one-on-one
it's cool to see I love those kind of
action sequences awesome but from a
character perspective and from this film
perfectly well done what he did where he
memorized the entire code of all the
bank accounts and said to the guy you
can kill me you're just not getting any
of your money right now so he again the
bad guy was always two steps ahead of
Ethan in this film that point of the
film Ethan got two steps ahead of him in
the bag guy knew it and when he pulled
the plug I was like Ethan 1 what was
really cool was when he trapped him I
like how it was equal revenge
it wasn't like Tom Cruise like I had one
up your ass you know other than putting
him away it was like perfect vengeance
at that time like you can't really piss
off an audience with that because you're
like yeah you did that to Tom Cruise
yeah I know the way he trapped him and
just the with the glass of the smoking
was like deja vu got you back love I
loved it this one you see Ethan Hunt
have to think a lot on his tip like it's
not a whim it's a mental game yeah in
this film for [ __ ] love this movie
I love it it's the best one it's a rare
feeling yeah it's great well guys that's
our review for Mission Impossible rogue
nation if you're new to the channel you
get subscribed to the real rejects you
can check out Andrea on Twitter he
tweets a lot Twitter egg or 7-eleven
correct and wheat me you can follow me
on Facebook Instagram Twitter vine
periscope a lot more things than what he
has he's more the same thing he's like
the dough sakis man it's the most
interesting man alive
you know how joseki says stay thirsty my
friends I like to stay stay wet my
friends right